This
is the cow N.E.H. American English dialect recordings
collection produced with funding from the National Endowment for the Humanities
and the Center for Applied Linguistics. This is
tape number
fourteen
yesterday.
Somebody
nineteen forty
one a date which will
live in infamy United States
of America was suddenly on the
Liberty by naval and air forces of the
empire the United States was a
peace with that nation. At the solace
of things and Japan was in front of
safety with its government and
its looking called the maintenance of peace in the Pacific.
Indeed one of
the dominating. Squadron commands
bombing in the American island of Oahu
the W. bass of the earlier knighted state and his
colleague deliver the secretary of
state a formal reply to a
recent American medicine and while this
reply stated that it seemed useless to
the existing diplomatic negotiate it
contained no
threat or.
The facts.
It will be reported that the distance
from the
Pats makes it obvious that the attack was deliberately
planned many days or even weeks ago.
It's during the intervening time the
Japanese governments deliberately sought to to save
the United States by folks
statements Franklin's quote often
Pete's attack yesterday
on the why on the island has caused severe damage
it's the American naval and military for
its I regret to tell you the very many American lives.
I've been
lots in addition American sips of been reported
for people on the high seas between San
Francisco and hada little
notes yesterday. It's a drop in
the government also launched an attack against a
mother layouts last night Japanese forces
attacked
comps last night Japanese forces
attacked romps last night Stephany's parses
affects the Philippine island.
It's Last night the Japanese attacked
Kuwait and this morning the Japanese
attacked Midway.
It's far undertaken a surprise
pensive expending. The put civic
Irish
affects yesterday and the
day before. Themselves.
The people of the United States have already made their opinion
and well on the sand big
implications for the very life and safety of all and they
see as Commander increase of the Army and Navy.
I have directed that all measures be taken for the fans.
But all is well off the whole nation.
Remember the character of the fall off against us.
I
don't know how long it might take
us to the wall but come this premeditated
invasion the American people in the right just might will win.
So with
that
Soledad.
I believe that I and
separates the will of the Congress and the
people when I have
said that we will model it up then the Aso building of
the malls. But will make it better is that
this false predatory another again and
dangerous
threat.
Philip is exists there is no blinking at the
fact that all people. Oh territory and
zero interests are in grave danger
with confidence and all
forces with the UN funding the families
of people. We will gain
the another couple's crime. So help us God.
I don't.
All right. It's the fungus to
play that since the unprovoked
and sus suddenly attacked
by Japan. On Sunday the some US
seven nine hundred forty one a safe
wall has existed between the
United States and the Japanese Empire.
I
don't.
It's.